We know that for the pattern of i. It repeats after each fourth power. So for i
to the tenth, we would go to the cycle twice. And then we would start over. We
would have i, then negative 1. I to the tenth is really the same thing as i to
the sixth and i squared. They all equal negative 1. We can think of this a lot
like the arithemetic on a clock. A clock cycles every 12 hours, the hour hand
passes all the numbers, and gets to 12 and then starts over. Well, that's
similar to what's happening with i, so we'll start with i and then we'll have i
squared I-cube, either the fourth, either the fifth, either the sixth, either
the seventh, either the eighth, either the ninth, and finally either the tenth.
This is how we know either the tenth is really equal to i squared, which equals
negative 1. Our pattern repeats every four patterns of i